i want you to meet two viewers who are
dealing with a declutter
situation as a newly married couple
jarrett
and jill also known as the cows
they're right here in studio which is so
good i'm like i'm waving to you
hi there you are okay we're about i
don't know
50 feet away and jared i hear that
you're the tidy one in the house
yes yes i uh i have to clean immediately
i can't leave
anything around wow that's really handy
to live with i have to say
um yeah or you're guilty conscious every
five minutes
well you know jay leno who seems like
he's in a really long
like happy productive marriage he told
me once at a commercial break
that you have to marry your conscience
oh well
congratulations
all right well here is the goal here
all right so jill you have all this you
know shemata and trinkets and
bric-a-brac and
like things that mean a lot to you and i
have the same thing i really have my
little personal knick-knacks
that i keep and you know are dear to my
heart but you guys need a place to
organize them
and you need to make it look right and
you need to like function it
all and feng shui it so basically you
need a bookshelf and here's what we have
a bookshelf for you but the key
is that you have to build it together in
one hour
it's a newlywed challenge
i'm gonna be checking in with you guys
throughout the whole show because when i
was 14 and had my first apartment
i bought some stuff at ikea and i will
tell you they stayed
out and around me while i cried and
couldn't put any of it together so i've
been there
it's hard but if you can build those
beautiful shells before the show ends
i've got five thousand dollars for you
[Applause]
let's go all right okay so cowsers here
we go get those allen red chips going
five thousand dollars is on the line
good luck cousins how's it going with
the shelves
oh it's going all right we completed
step two we're on a three now
and how are you working together uh jill
tells me what to do and i do it
pretty much that's super smart how long
have you guys been married
uh 30 days tomorrow yeah 30 days
it's jill's birthday today
happy birthday i'm so happy i get to
spend it with drew
i am so happy i get to spend your
birthday with you too and oh my gosh all
right well keep going on those shelves
again
i was in i was by myself i didn't have a
partner when i got all my furniture when
i was 14 in my first apartment so you
guys have each other
this is great go go five thousand
dollars is on the line
by the end of the show go
go it's time to check in with the
cowsers i was at the news desk and i was
like i can't help it i gotta just gotta
come over here how's it going i think
we're finished
it looks like a bookshelf to me drew
didn't this bookshelf have more shelves
or are you just saying you're
stacking large items in there i mean
there could be some really big books
all my trinkets are different sizes so
this works
and that's why they make adjustable
shelves exactly
there you go jarrett was even like oh
i've got time to like start like
dusting and stuff i had to keep it clean
for drew i love it i think you guys have
done an amazing job
[Applause]
do you think you're gonna get five
thousand dollars
what is the first thing you're gonna put
in that shelf
first oh what are you putting on the
shelf all my birthday cards from how
cute i'm praying a ps5 fits here somehow
perfect you heard that that's what we
call it his and hers all right
we'll be right back
i'm with jill and jarrett and they are
an awesome couple he's neat
she's messy but i was curious with your
yin yang styles what's your favorite
thing
about each other if i had to answer i
would say it's jill's heart
while she's a a mess in the house she
puts everything together for her family
and friends and
we all love her so oh my god oh chill
top that one i know talk about pressure
um jared he he he's neat and he keeps me
together
and you know there's no one who i rather
have on my team
to make sure that everything is going
right and you guys are a great team
thank you and you know we are not you
are two people
one love and you have your different
styles and keep like
celebrating that about each other as i
celebrate the way that you love each
other because i love love and i am so
happy i got to hang out with you today
you won five thousand bucks
because you lay your love of life thank
you everyone for tuning in
you